so i'm calling a sperm bank or it's a
fertility center
right
yes
they have this is a place jackie where
for fertility where you can
they call it thank you for calling the
california
that's what i'm the leading experts in
fertility
we are in the office but currently
helping other patients if you know your
party's extension please dial it at any
time
for front office assistance please press
one to reach one of our dedicated nurses
right
the nurses it doesn't matter
is that a pre-production can you please
hold um
should i just hold it or just hold on
what are you saying
can you just please hold on the line oh
yeah thanks yeah one second you don't
know when you call a
fertility center or a sperm bank and
they say hold on you don't know
what they're saying to hold on and
they're rapidly evolving i know this is
in the hole
as a leader with a unique and
comprehensive
there we are here we go
hi
hi um what are your hours i'd like to
come in and pick up uh
does it go by pints or quartz as far as
sperm collection how does it go
you are you a a
patient of the office no but i i read
about your uh
your operation there and i'm i'm willing
to come in and is it do you have curb
service or
do i can i come in and pick up sperm or
how does it work what are the increments
let me transfer you to the office
manager one second this looks like a job
for the office manager
yeah okay all right
i'm going to be talking to you right to
the manager that's how i work
all right
all right
um
or we can call uber jizz
isn't there uber jizz
sorry to keep you holding me help you oh
no problem so i just wanted to know the
increments of uh sperm collection is it
pints or is it uh cups or how does it go
and how much if i uh do you deliver or
do i just pick it up on my own
i'm sorry we didn't we're not a sperm
bank oh i know but you do sperm
collections right
well for patients that are trying to get
pregnant yes right so what if and that's
what we're trying to do too so how do i
uh
how do i is it curbside or do i just
come in and pick it up or how do i get
it
well when you come in for your
consultation dr wu will explain it all
to you but we give you um
a sterile cup and you collect at home if
that's what you want to do no no i want
to come in i want to get the sperm from
you and bring it home to my wife as a
kind of a gift
we don't have sperm here sir you have no
sperm there
no we don't we're all females here no
i'm not asking for your sperm i'm
talking about you must have sperm that
has been collected in these cups they're
kind of no we don't we don't keep sperm
sir we're not a sperm bank no i know
that's why i want to come and take it
home but what do your what do you mean
take it home
i'm sorry i don't for my
you do takeout is what i'm saying the
the thing is that what my wife is trying
to get pregnant how do you get pregnant
without sperm you guys collect sperm in
the cups i want to come and pick up some
cups
okay
when you're a patient of the office
we'll give you some yes
you give me sperm
a cup not sperm a cup why can't i get
sperm can i buy sperm we don't have
sperm hair you we don't have how can you
not have sperm at a fertility clinic how
does the fertility
i don't go ahead no okay
the sperm is collected
at the lab we're not the last drop the
mic clinic drop the mic the sperm is
collected at the lab okay right can you
and you are in direct contact with the
lab
yes i'm calling you to say i need sperm
i got i have two cups
uh uh well
my my wife is at home and her friend
okay
and they told me to call you to get the
the sperm so they're waiting at home and
i'm supposed to bring home a cup of this
for them
i'm sorry we don't do services like that
sir i'm not asking you to service i'm
asking just to give me your office hours
the amount of sperm i could collect and
how do i take that one cup back to the
two girls
i don't know i'm sorry i don't have the
answer to that question
it's so simple i have two girls one cup
so why do you need to bring the sperm
here sir you're not our patient we don't
collect sperm from patients
i'm collecting the sperm i'm trying to
come there to collect the sperm
so you want to use our room to collect
your sperm and then take it back to your
wife
no to the two girls we don't do that no
i don't want to do that i don't want to
use the room
i want the whoever you i don't care
where it comes from i just want a cup of
sperm to take home that's it okay we
don't have i can give you an empty cup
yes
that's not what now you're being are you
being smart with me
i'm not being smart with you sir but we
don't do it i i thought i was calling a
professional place
and this is a professional place and we
don't collect sperm here i'm not telling
you to collect the sperm i'm telling you
to give me the sperm
just one cup of sperm from where
the cup
i'm sorry i don't understand what your
question is i guess i'm stupid i don't
know i didn't call you stupid do not
call yourself stupid we do not use that
word in this house
you are not stupid you're a very smart
person
and i have two girls here i'm asking for
one cup
what do i do
you can come here for a cup we can give
you an empty cup i have no problem with
that what am i supposed to do with an
empty cup where are you going to get the
sperm
i don't know sir you have to buy the
sperm from a sperm bank if you're not
going to use your own sperm
why would i use my own sperm
i don't know do you want to purchase
sperm i can refer you somewhere
okay send me to the sperm purchasing
is it do they have it there's no sperm
at costco is there
no is there any uh we'd have to go to a
bank that has it frozen there sir
frozen i don't want we live in southern
california i don't want frozen sperm i'm
not trying to
create frozen people
um
what are you planning on doing with this
sperm sir
what am i planning on doing i just want
to pick it up and take it the cup to the
two girls
and what are they gonna do with this sir
i think now you're getting too personal
just give me the price the amount let me
come in answers to the question so that
way i know where to direct you i'm
coming for the [ __ ] that's it that's what
i'm saying
coming for the come ready or not until 5
pm here i come 5 p.m thank you bye
[Music]
bye